every year it happens like clockwork
where does the next iPhone Joanna should
I wait for the next iPhone I'm due for
an upgrade soon so when does the next
iPhone come out okay okay I get it I get
it you think I have a direct line into
Johnny Ives iPhone lab I don't but I do
know when the next iPhone is coming out
because history let's review the last
four iPhones were announced during the
second week of September and then began
shipping about ten or so days later so
if I was a betting woman I would put my
money on the next iPhone being announced
on September 13th and yes I think you
should wait for it it's long been my
advice that by the time June rolls
around you should wait for the next
model and let me tell you about the next
model by looking into my crystal ball it
won't have a major redesign or even a
headphone port but the tower isn't for
some big changes and it might be
water-resistant just like the Samsung
Galaxy s7 and that's what you're really
waiting for to see if the new features
put it ahead of the Samsung the best
phone you can buy right now here's where
the iPhone really needs to rise to
Samsung's challenge the camera
the latest leaked photos and reports
suggest that Apple's next camera will
get a big upgrade and the bigger screen
iPhone 7 plus will have two lenses on
the back to improve overall photo
quality and add depth of field now I
want everyone to breathe in and out
listen to the calming music do not freak
out it appears very likely that Apple
will remove the headphone jack on the
next iPhone
in and out better get used to that
headphone port going away my colleagues
at the Journal report that it will be
removed and instead you'd use wireless
headphones or plug headphones into the
Lightning charging port the upside it
would make the phone thinner and also
would help with making it
water-resistant there are two
improvements I will be very angry if we
don't see one the battery life on the
iPhone hasn't improved in two years
Apple this is not the answer to storage
according to my sources the base iPhone
will start at 32 gigabytes not 16
gigabytes if that happens it'll be a
September mirror call Apple declined to
comment on any of this reporting now if
your phone's really on its last legs
here's some advice go grab a $40 battery
case like this anchor to get back some
battery life if your screen is broken
use a service like I cracked to replace
it for as low as $100 it will up the
trade-in or resale value look you may
end up deciding you even want the iPhone
7 or whatever Apple decides to call it
but you deserve to weigh it as an option
plus the price on the iPhone 6s will
drop and that galaxy s7 it'll still be
around